reprises cette semaine du procès des
attentats djihadistes de janvier 2015
après un mois de suspension une
interruption liée à l'état de santé du
principal accusé ali riza bolat atteinte
du cauvel 19
ce dernier est jugé pour complicité de
crimes terroristes par la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris
les audiences auraient dû prendre fin le
10 novembre beaucoup de retard a été
pris donc le point avec katia technique
ce matin au tribunal de paris vient les
avocats des parties civiles un de
charlie hebdo encore de l'hyper cacher
c'est en effet avec beaucoup de retard
qu'on va entendre les personnalités à là
bas vous le savez vous l'avais dit il ya
eu des suspensions à cause du coc vide
mais des retards pris par ce que il ya
des injonctions à comparaître beaucoup
de discussions sur la bonne tenue du
procès et donc il ya eu des retards
importants mais nous avons pu enfin
entendre m patrick klugman ce matin qui
a axé sa plaidoirie sur l'antisémitisme
ça difficile reconnaissance en france
par exemple concernant le chef
d'inculpation vis-à-vis des clients de
l'hyper cacher il s'agit de simples
séquestration sans le motif aggravante
de l'antisémitisme ce qui paraît
étonnant donc maître patrick klugman
c'est vraiment emporter a demandé que ce
soit requalifiée il a également tenu des
propos très fort sur le climat délétère
jamais un procès contre le terrorisme en
france 2 s'était tenu dans un tel
environnement de terreur at il asséné la
terreur est partout devant vous parmi
nous et puis évidemment toutes ces
plaidoiries sont l'occasion de rappeler
cette souffrance infinie des victimes
des parties civiles
et puis leur deuil impossible nous
sommes entretenus tout à l'heure avec
samia maktouf qui est l'avocate de
lassana bathily le magazine et de
l'hyper cacher on les écoute
en tant qu avocat de parties civiles
j'ai essayé de préciser le préjudice
subi par mon client
du fait de cet attentat l'hyper cacher
cette douleur qui l'accompagnent
cette souffrance cette peur la peur
d'être de subir
des représailles il s'était très
important de parler des victimes parce
que nous sommes les voix de ses victimes
et ses victimes
elles se sont succédé à la barre pour
parler de leur traumatisme
elles l'ont fait avec beaucoup de
courage et de dignité et c'était très
important aujourd'hui
au troisième jour des plaidoiries des
parties civiles d'en reparler
et d'expliquer ce syndrome du survivant
pour les victimes qui ont eu la chance
d'échapper à ce face à face avec la mort
donc des plaidoiries très intense très
poignante qui réclame des peines très
lourdes pour les accusés et nous
attendons cet après midi la plaidoirie
de richard malka